yo what's up guys is prestige and we got  some origin zombies gameplay from the  apocalypse DLC now this is gonna be a  video but the to prove the new guns to  the mp40 and the stg44 you just saw you  use the mp40 it rekt it has a job and  get always this adjustable stock and I'm  not sure and then we have the STG the  STG is pretty good the mp40 can be found  around the map you can pick a band for  anywhere like there are lots of places  but the stg44 you have to get the  mansion in the back and if you know  where i'm just get to the back of the  map somehow and it's gonna be in the  upper level of the mansion you're gonna  see up in the up right there  that big mansion so hope you guys  enjoyed if you did make sure to leave a  like rate comment or subscribe peace out